des nouvelles du Père Noël après avoir
dit quelques mots aux enfants de rovanie
il a quitté la Laponie sur son prénom
pour distribuer ses cadeaux dans le
monde entier c'est Noël et chacun rêve
d'une trêve
je rêve de contrôleurs qui contrôlaient
de conducteurs qui conduisent c'est Noël
et vous serez peut-être donné en famille
si vous rejoignez les vôtres ce ne sera
pas un voyage dans l'espace mais dans le
temps quand on reçoit autant de cadeaux
une seule solution tout essayé en même
temps magie de Noël on peut faire du
vélo en combinaison d'astronautes
tu regardes l'émission de temps en temps
oui je regarde quasiment tous les
apéritifs
certains toutous seront même plus gâtés
que leur maître et là sa propre
chaussette elle l'américaine sur le
cheminée et il est bien rempli des
cadeaux par terre aussi voilà
[Musique]
on pensait au petit tour sur qu'il en a
déjà un donc voilà et donc on s'est dit
que c'était assez marrant parce que
ça couine
[Rires]
c'est drôle certains sont même gâtés
avant l'heure par des bonhommes de neige
comestibles et du coup donc ça je vais
les planter et du coup après elles vont
arriver elles vont être surprises par
toute cette décoration et après elles
vont découvrir parce que je leur ai fait
des petits cadeaux des petits cadeaux
dont l'espérance de vie dans l'enclos et
très limité je suis dans une boulangerie
mais c'est quoi que vous avez une bûche
abandon
qui est mis en vente dans le dans cette
boulangerie le petit Mozart qui est très
bien donc ils l'ont mis en vente depuis
hier soir et curieusement ils n'en ont
pas vendu pas vendu
bah ça se passe plutôt bien parce que
c'est un métier difficile qu'on fait
c'est pas toi que je vais la prendre on
a des gens qui sont formidables et
honnêtes et on a des armada d'altringue
et dans ces cas-là c'est quand même plus
agréable de travailler en famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Nicolas il propose de renommer notre
compétition nous on appelle Noël des
Champions mais Nicolas a trouvé une
autre idée une autre appellation qui est
peut-être sympa c'est une amie qui me
l'a soufflé et elle voudrait qu'on
renomme ça question pour un super Noël
et ben c'est pas mal on l'a l'image du
49-3 je crois qu'on l'a laissé
je précise que c'est une photo pourquoi
c'est une photo c'est la montage c'est
pas c'est pas une photo
madame borne a toujours ses bras un vent
polaire de la neige et des températures
glaciales c'est le cocktail explosif qui
est en train de s'abattre sur la moitié
des États-Unis les experts prédisent
déjà une bombe cyclonique comme on en
voit une fois par génération
sur les routes enneigées au nord du pays
la visibilité est quasi nulle
et comment ça fait un petit peu chaud je
sais pas si vous le sentez je monte au
fur et à mesure là j'ai monté à
température à 2500 watts on puisse du
coup intensifier un petit peu tout ça la
pièce va donc atteindre les 32 degrés et
l'activité devient plus intense moi
j'aime la chaleur et j'ai vraiment du
mal à transpirer mais ça commence à
faire chaud avec les exercices face à
ces températures extrêmes les
générateurs et lignes électriques n'ont
pas résisté
un million de personnes sont désormais
sans électricité
je suis content d'avoir une cheminée
sinon là je serai en train de geler
est-ce que vous voulez un bisou magique
de votre chérie ou de moi j'arrive
[Applaudissements]
des bisous tout doux oh là là c'est trop
vite
[Musique]
pour les plus chanceux ces températures
sont aussi l'occasion de se lancer des
défis certains se filment en train de
jeter de l'eau bouillante en l'air
elle se transforme en glace avant même
d'avoir atteint le sol chez les
Guichards mes enfants ils sont grands
pour la plupart d'entre eux ils vivent
leur vie pour la plupart d'entre eux et
je passe Noël tranquille
oui le Père Noël vient pu le voir je
voulais vous dire que moi je préfère
largement passer ma soirée avec vous oui
qu'avec les autres cons de ma famille je
vous le dis tout de suite
tu dis ça devant mes beaux-parents
[Musique]
1 2 3